la première chose qu'on ressent quand on
approche du glacier sentiment
d'immensité tout ce qu'on entend en fait
c'est le silence
on se sent comme au milieu le désert ou
sur la lune c'est un sentiment très
isolants mais qui en même temps très
très inspirant
le glacis c'est une masse de glace qui
est plutôt bien donc les glaciers en
général ont quelques centaines voire
quelques millions d'années en âge c'est
une masse qui est que nous on imagine
comme étant plutôt immobile mais qui est
assez dynamique si positive donc les
glaces y ont des cycles de fonte et de
jls selon les saisons mais aussi des
cycles de forme qui sont sur des
échelles de temps beaucoup plus que plus
grande et plus on en est affectée par
des choses comme les changements
climatiques
quand on regarde une carotte de glace
par exemple un espèce de longs tubes on
ne voit que de la glace me voir des
strates selon l'âge de l'accumulation de
la neige et de la glace qu'on veuille
voir on découvre qu'il disait cette vie
qu'il est absolument étonnante surtout
pour un environnement qui est aussi
froid aussi désertique
on veut retrouver une quantité
incroyable de virus de bactéries de
micro organismes unicellulaires qui ne
sont pas figées dans la glace en fait
tous ces organismes là vivent dans un
écosystème qui est très dynamique et
très complexe les glaciers fondent de
manière accélérée le nord et la région
du globe qui se réchauffe le plus
rapidement et le plus intensément dans
un globe
et puis en fait on comprend peut très
bien toutes les conséquences de cette
fonte on ne sais pas qu'est ce que ces
microbes qui sont libérés par les
écosystèmes modèle
peut faire ces micro-organismes qui
sortent des glaces emma peuvent
transiter vers les écosystèmes d'eau
douce en aval doivent être transférés
vers l'atmosphère puis ensuite dispersé
dans l'environnement qui on ne connaît
pas en fait leurs identifiants connaît
pas leur vie il ya un cas de figure qui
est assez célèbre est plutôt triste
alors 2016 en sibérie en fait on est
venu à faire à une épidémie d'anthrax
due à la fonte du pergélisol dans la
région qui a tué des centaines de règne
a même effectué quelques humains donc on
a vraiment un recyclage de microbes
anciens vers les écosystèmes moderne
on ne sait pas trop qui sont si
micro-organismes qu'est ce qu'ils font
est un monsieur un risque auquel on doit
être préparé évidemment ça peut sembler
alarmistes de pensée qui est des
maladies comme l'anthrax qui peuvent
émerger du pergélisol ou des glaciers en
fonte
il faut savoir par contre c'est que la
très grande majorité des microbes
écrivant les bactéries les virus
n'infecte police mais je m'intéresse à
ces microbes lé parce qu'il infecte pas
les humains mais parce qu'ils vont
infecter d'autres hôtes dans les
écosystèmes
ils vont affecter par exemple d'autres
micro-organismes les poissons les
plantes les animaux les mammifères dans
le milieu arctique et puis ça ça parle
des conséquences sur les chaînes
alimentaires moderne